welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down what
if throughout this video we're going to
be going through all the Easter eggs
hidden details and things you might have
missed in it now obviously the both of
you the both of you that religiously
follow the channel you're probably like
why you doing episode 5 mate where's one
to four where is it well I just want to
offer my sincerest sincerest apologies
but man had to swap Theory time for
family time at Christmas my editors also
requested the week off to be with s too
and that's your boys going solo on this
one I write the videos host the videos
edit the videos too but yeah I just
didn't have time to do those first four
however I'll try and cover as much as I
can and I hope you guys are with me so
we can watch them together and hit the
thumbs up together have to say though
I've really enjoyed the season so far
and I think it's been Leaps and Bounds
above season 1 anyway I hope you had an
amazing Christmas and what I wanted was
the same thing that Steve wanted that is
Peggy C I mean the Hydra Stompers suit
which is what this episode centers
around now Peggy is of course a
returning character with her being what
kickstarted the first episode of what if
she of course also featured a Multiverse
of Madness and showed that she couldn't
do this all day still though it's nice
to see her back as she's genuinely one
of my favorite spin-off characters in
the MCU man's even got the t-shirt and I
also own both the steelbook Agents of
cter she's like the bloody Queen to me
and we see in her world how important
she was to The Avengers kickstarting
with a scene pulled directly from the
film we watch as the group fed out on
the bridge that leads up to Central
Station not sure what it's called Uh but
moving on several shots here rip off the
moments in the movie including Black
Widow taking down chitari with their own
weapons Widow also mentions her
childhood in Moscow foreshadowing
several events in the episode from here
we could both Iron Man and Hawkeye but
there's a different member instead of
the Hulk here we can catch the WASP with
her being a member of the team
originally in the comics she of course
featured earlier in the season as well
and it's nice to get a Marvel com iic
main stay you of course can't play on
stuff like this without doing the
Avengers Assemble moment which actually
appears twice in this entry we then see
as the Leviathan descends from the sky
with cod's line ripping off Steve's in
the movie so cap what's the plan po Kai
wasp I one eyes in the sky I want you on
that roof eyes on everything call out
patterns and Strays Iron Man Thor keep
the fighting down here dark you got the
perimeter anything gets more than three
blocks out you turn it back or you turn
it to Ash give me lift right Widow let's
go for a r
I like it you and me we stay here on the
ground we keep the fighting here and
Hulk smash rather than saying Hulk smash
though she and Widow go for a ride this
of course builds off the back of what
happens in the film with Carter also
using the shield to boost her up at
Avengers Tower they take down Loi and
you better hope man doesn't wipe his ass
with this timeline anyway I was
surprised at some of the voice cast cuz
it sounded like a lot of them were just
voice actors that were just doing
impressions but no Sam Jackson at well
Frank gillow Sebastian Stan Rachel wise
an Elizabeth olssen they're all in it
and maybe I need to get my hearing
checked out or something anyway we C to
The Watcher where we see him in between
the Multiverse this is similar to what
showed up in the infinite Ultron episode
with the Widow sh coming directly from
that there alsoo Thanos from episode 2
and Iron Man when the Avengers were
killed by Hank Pim focusing on Peggy he
replaced the clips from our episode
while we can catch the zombie episode
clip and gamora's one too lastly we get
moments from the finale and see that
assembles one before then heading out
the limbo bar seeing Peggy drive along
we then get a flip on the start of
Winter Soldier in that it was Natasha
picking up Steve whereas here that's the
one that's been jogging in the back we
can also catch the Washington Monument
which of course was the route that Steve
used to take Nat she was Bloody she was
Bloody calling Steve a fossil and then
we dive into another moment from the end
of season 1 that is at the Luman star
which is of course also from Winter
Soldier in the film this was where
project Insight was supposed to launch
satellites from but the ship was
hijacked by George Bat Rock we know from
the end of season 1 that they fought bat
rock as well but I'm not sure what's
going on cuz Bucky barns is in charge
here this is instead of Alexander Pierre
so Insight isn't happening unless Agents
of Shield timeline still going down
where it was made in the 70s also I love
how Peggy suits more in line with how
Steves was in that film I know that it's
been in the series before but here it
just makes way more sense now if you
love clothes sham plug we're actually
selling an all connected shirt right
below the video it's all connected you
know it's dead funny when I say that
isn't it everyone sitting about laughing
uh so if you want to buy that and give
me money for it then yeah just click
that below and we'll love you forever
the reason they're here is instead to
investigate the Hydra stomper which has
been found inside a storage container I
was thinking right uh I'm sure the
season 1 final they didn't have red
rockets in the Soviet stuff but nope
went back and that had it in so yeah
they had this ready to go but I wasn't
expecting it to turn this bad whereas
Peggy became cap cap became the Winter
Soldier which means he's been
brainwashed to be a sovet asset the
Hydra stomper designs also changed too
so now it looks more in line with the
iron manga you might also notice there's
red stars on the shoulder plates which
highly resemble what was on Buy's arm
anyway KN calls him RoboCop which Peggy
says thata hasn't seen what do you mean
you haven't seen it go to Arrow films
they're doing a sale right now if you
use the code heavy spoilers where you'll
get 10% off and you can buy Rob our cop
on 4K now this is riffing off the Winter
Soldier when Steve kept an outad of all
the stuff that he needed to catch up on
Peggy however she isn't that interested
cuz deep down she's a completely
different person this is also why she
wasn't jogging either and I appreciate
them sort of being opposites to each
other still though she's got feelings
for Steve as we get a slow motion fly by
where the parlock eyes Steve and ends up
flying into the sky and I was wondering
if they were going to have it icing over
guessing the Soviets dealing with the C
figured out before the Americans dead
and he ends up raining down missiles
from the air now from here we cut to
Nick's office which is also pull
directly from the film Legends of the
Hydra stomper have been whispered
throughout the ages in the same vein
that Bucky was said to be out there
however they've added in a curve ball
with this now being caused by the Red
Room Hydra has been likely stomped out
by the Hydra stomper so instead it's the
Red Room that's now brainwashed him we
also have Bucky in charge so they didn't
infect him and use him to take over the
world Pier is missing and look i' stop
going on about it you get it now at this
point we get a wide shot of the tri
scallion which in many ways is an
opposite to the Red Room the Red Room is
sort of a dark mirror of it in which it
operates from the skies hidden in the
clouds this is using helic carrier Tech
which helps it to remain in orbit
undetected inside we also catch the
other characters from The Winter Soldier
like councilman Singh councilwoman Hy
and councilman Rockwell you also get
this line about the sovian aid package
surely you understand that the a
packages I won't have a country torn
apart by Civil War because we didn't do
the right thing and the sovian Accords
of course showed up in Civil War which
hey it's a nice little line at this
point crossbones Pops in but due to him
not being Hydra he's actually there to
help and then attacked by the Hydra
stomper and we also see the command
center from The Winter Soldier things
are broken up though by Steve arriving
which also takes us in of the lobby that
Steve bust into pulling off moves
similar to Star we see is Steve uses his
back to bust a the jet this is similar
to what happened in Iron Man was getting
another Avengers reference in the next
shot when the Hulk busts free a jet puts
its sights on him which appears similar
to how it does here now Bucky tries to
appeal to their P but Rogers refuses to
lower his
arms this is something that happens
later with Peggy showing how much that
she means to him Peggy's the one that
can break the hold and make it so that
he has to let go but I'm not a rapper
knocked out they're picked up by the
Widow and at this point they fly out to
St kers this is in Scotland which is
something that hasn't popped up in
Marvel before and it's completely off of
Shield's books I'm guessing that this
was a retreat for Widow back in the days
when she worked for the Red Room we also
learned that it's the suit that's
preserving Steve and that this is what's
kept him alive however removing it will
kill him unless he sort of become a
monster trapped in the machine described
as biotech each time he's deploy the
odds of his survival then Dro
drastically to me this is why they want
Peggy instead so they can replaces
soldier with something else also the way
they pulled Steve away and have
retreated is a bit like what they did
with buy during Civil War instead of Sam
and Steve we have Bucky and Nat who will
do whatever they can to protect Steve
Rogers now Peggy says how he could wind
up frozen in carbonite which you get
mate yet give yourself a pat on the back
for getting that one deciding to go to
the Red Room we learn the previous owner
drov was tracked down and killed by now
who is a character that of course
appeared during Black Widow however due
to its ability to move the red room's
been constantly going and is almost
untraceable from here they travel out to
a sovian military base again building
off the back of Civil War this is
basically a nuke town set up to carry
out tests and it resembles a 1950s one
like we saw in Indiana Jones Peggy says
I feel like I'm in a horror movie and we
once fought a giant space squid calling
back to the time she fought schuma
gorath or or was it go anua either way
the olden Town gives Peggy and Steve
time to reminisce and we can hear it's
been a long long time playing in the
background this was something Steve
played in his apartment in Winter
Soldier and it's also of course what
Peggy and Steve danced to the pair were
destined to be but life got in the way
and unfortunately they never got to be
together at this point Peggy's hit with
a widow bite which is a weapon we've
seen bust out in several of their
appearances the town turn on them and we
get the pair smashing them like it's a
like button which is when we get a bird
sizee shot this reminds me a lot of the
opening of Ragnarok in which we saw Thor
throwing around mul Widow also talks
about how they didn't get cable TV in
Russia and wonder of course had to watch
old sitcoms on VHS to keep her
entertained in the end Molina arrives
with her taking over the position of
drov in the power vacuum she's also
joined by a group of widows who resemble
the ones that we saw on Black Widow as
we saw now Molina was a maternal figure
with Widow also referring to her as that
she was working with drov secretly so
her being here yeah it does make sense
now it's at this point we learned
Steve's true Mission which was to bring
in Peggy the plan was to lure her away
from the Avengers and shield with her
being all that they've wanted the entire
time also there's no Red Guardian in
this universe because the Russians
weren't inspired by Steve Rogers instead
all the girls apparently used to look up
to her which has somewhat inspired the
widows anyway it leads to all kicking
off and we see as Widow takes on the
widows while Peggy faces Steve we get
him shooting her with a Gatling gun
which leads to a similar shot that we
got with Steve against Bucky this is of
course a similar situation with both
having to deal with someone from their
past in the end she manages to convince
them by bringing up the de heoa which is
of course what the man traveled through
time to do man was desperate but to be
fair I would do too cuz godamn check
that godamn he decides to sacrifice
himself and basically Independence Day
the Red Room up your this pulls Molina
along with it duud to Widow lassoing her
to Steve now it seems like he's gone
Peggy still holds out hope hitting up
Tony's garage he goes to head out with
Widow but at this point she gets pulled
through realities now this is likely the
16002 which we know is going to be
coming in the season seems like both
wonder and Nick here are in E old timely
clothes and they tease something going
on in their reality that is she the one
who can save our Queen now we'll of
course be back for that and I hope
you've enjoyed us going through this if
you have yet it's Christmas mate hit the
thumbs up button and hopefully I'll see
you tomorrow you better come back and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler societ then please
click the join button for 99 cents and
99 p a month you'll get early access to
breakdowns and also our podcast you know
the want I do with Greg if not then up
yours mate uh but yeah come back
tomorrow please and uh if you want
something else to watch and there's a
video on screen right now huge thank you
for coming to boxing day with me and
yeah I'll see you after this peace
byebye